[Music]
in our IP legend news no oh submitted by
vermilion remilia NER no we're gonna
talk about Spike Lee oh you guys know
that do you guys know that that the
newspaper they they [ __ ] up they'd be
right yeah okay Oh worried yeah yeah
okay so there's a picture of Stanley
if this Spike Lee dies hilarious I know
it's so [ __ ] up Godfather
Marvel Comics has passed away at 95
years old so sad - I was behind hurry up
in my room man I know you dude yeah and
get this like I know people that's
worked with him and they said like this
was this year actually earlier this year
they recorded some stuff with him and
they're like this guy is so mentally
sharp they're like he's so young still
like in his brain like everyone's like
like when we were filming with them he
just went through the script like this
in a one-take he was able to hit
everything in the car oh yeah and then
an interline whoa and he's like I told
you I've been doing this for a long time
all [ __ ] cocky and [ __ ] I never
thought it was gonna die like I knew it
was all this but anybody did but it was
just my news in his 90s but you just see
him in all these cameos and he's super
sharp by Joe saying and I just never
thought he was gonna be like 120 passive
they still haven't said but you passed
of overdose of imagination there's
Stanley did like it's so funny cuz like
afterwards like the next day I was like
looking at some Stanley clips and I was
like man dude it's full biggest [ __ ]
dweeb I've ever seen in my life yeah
that's a BS [ __ ] yeah but he's so he's
like that dude in the sense of like what
I mean by DB is like he stayed that
comic book nerd kid all the way till he
was 95 like so dog like he did not let
adulthood change his perspective on life
other that's [ __ ] crazy
I think that's [ __ ] awesome cuz all
the characters he created that he
probably got beat up for twenty times
yep like when he was a kid he was like
[ __ ] you guys I'm gonna keep drawing
this [ __ ] and there's like a giant
fanbase International when I was reading
about him is that he changed comic books
because he was the one that introduced
the superheroes to be more like human
like it had more adult problems now mmm
be like more grown-up any pie got beat
up for that to excel see or bow bow q
isn't trying to market it to just kids
anymore like he changed it to where like
he was marketing it to adults best mark
Tom because of him so many young teens
were pimply and didn't shower my those
little [ __ ] no God Mandy why did you
cry I think it's just cuz like anybody
who affected me as a child like it just
it starts to bring up things that I
didn't realize how important this person
was to me you know what I mean like
Stanley or like one [ __ ] mr. Rogers
passed away mmm
I found a mr. Rogers passed away I was
coming back from the Men's Wearhouse
when I was working a part-time job I
heard it on the [ __ ] radio I was like
honest so sad I started [ __ ] tearing
up because I used to watch mr. Rogers as
a kid a lot when I was a kid over and
over for me was Robin Williams
Oh Robin Williams I teared up to like
it's so weird like you don't realize how
important these people aren't even if
you haven't met them but they kind of
like help build like the foundation of
your life you know what I mean Bill
Cosby even though he's a little [ __ ]
rape rape oh guy I love this show he
passes away I'm gonna cry too cuz The
Cosby Show was is my favorite sitcom of
all time
now you've got me thinking about who I'm
a miss when they pass away Rachael Ray
i'ma cry Rachael Ray mm-hmm Cooke EVO
still do Savior I'll be sittin there
poor my olive oil crying like this you
[ __ ] oh my god that's the widest thing
about you do but Rachael Ray 30 she's
shoving right she's why is she southern
get that she's latina or something I'm
not sure she was looking to me she I
think she might be Italian why y'all
know I have somebody that you'd be like
oh really I'm hung Oh Willa
we saw him in Vegas no was why the way
with the Julia Child is jackboot pan and
the Ming Tsou or the people or means I
am sorry I mean side were the three
people I saw right oh and then also
[ __ ] Martin yin dude that bull dies
I'm crying dude who the hell is this
button yeah dude right oh that sounds
awful yeah welcome if I think I'd be
like oh my Will Smith - for sure that's
my friend but then I don't give a [ __ ]
if anybody dies though yes only my
friends and family but like there's not
like that one person this like creeping
up there and age and you be like oh no
this is it well it's mainly musicians
cuz then I feel like last year or the
year before we had so many good people
like it was like plants and then let
another one and it just kept going down
like that and I was I just know I'm
Justin Bieber's pretty good just
somebody else cuz I feel like there's so
many legends that I think any of the
Paul brothers oh yeah but nobody cares
about them yeah they're not dying the
same world it's musicians
oh yeah a musician yeah when Elliott
Elliott alia was sad I was Aaliyah for
Halloween last year you know my friend
in sixth grade thought Stan Lee was
Korean only cuz his last name well cuz I
didn't so so he he was he believed that
Marvel was a Korean creation oh my he
was so [ __ ] good at like drawing like
Wolverine and all these guys and so like
he would draw all this [ __ ] for us
and he's like yeah Stan Lee's Korean and
when he found out he just stopped trying
I don't know if he ever do I
I believe he was Korean because he told
me that everything yeah yeah I think the
last celebrity ID for was to pop can be
not Michael Jack old we you did IPOs in
junior high like seventh grade Oh
Michael Jackson why mourn for Michael
Jack I remember we were we were together
driving the pasady
a blue truck and we're just listening it
was on our one of our anniversary yeah
and I so I remember the exact moment and
it hit me hard but I didn't cry I think
I was a little bit older already and
that was our childhood what do you mean
no but I mean like that's still weird
cuz I do remember exactly where I was
soon that was frozen I was definitely
paralyzed but I didn't like ball mm-hmm
I remember Isaac was a baby she was like
so little and I was holding him in the
bedroom and I was like I was gonna get
that this is it concert tickets yeah
yeah we were ten we were too but then I
we watched a movie instead what I came
after like I'm trying think of like
other celebrities that I grew up with
watching that I think they passed away
they would affect me but although I get
the [ __ ] out here right now Michael
Jackson oh you're here I miss him
I still watch stuff about him all the
time passes away I can't pick a [ __ ] kid
I'll be either one of those guys on
things every medallion is so checked
he's [ __ ] buff as hell dude I don't
think anyone even knows what Jackie Chan
Jackie Chan dies on crying oh oh that's
a good one Jackie Chan guys I'm crying
dude you know what is because like those
are the people that we grew up watching
so like when we see that passed away
were like oh my god like that's a real
toy yeah like if we saw Britney Spears
die because she's only like what she
might be like 38
yeah but Britney Spears like five years
from dying at this point is she abused
her body so much oh my god shout out to
Britney though yeah how you destruction
and a shout-out to Britt hey I like
Brittany dude she was hailey I see Jim
Carrey how he old he looks now that's so
crazy
yeah it's me right damn he looks like
Jim grandpa no no I don't even know if
you could play comedic roles anymore
because his face looks so traumatic now
Oh like he got tired
yeah like yes just like a whether face I
also don't think he cares anymore if
y'all seen those weird Jim Carrey
interviews where he's like the
universe's cosmic and nothing really
matters you did a lot of acid have you
seen his art oh yes
amazing I want to own one of the
interesting [ __ ] doesn't he
who's like the whole table and [ __ ] it's
like human psyche and yeah he's like
hovering over it and then it's like
doing it's like a 12-foot canvas he's
[ __ ] paying this [ __ ] he's an
interesting - he's so artistic
do you though armie hammer he played the
twins in social network armie hammer
yeah yeah yeah he was also in the call
me by your name he died - no that is a
really high turtleneck yeah yeah it's
just crazy
looks like foreskin I was looking at
Thanks here's it up saying I can't we do
something out his name's army man yeah
he tweeted out so touched by all the
celebrities posting pictures of
themselves with Stanley no better way to
commemorate an absolute legend than
putting up a picture of yourself he's
talking about like I wish I had a
picture with Stanley and then like wait
you saw you [ __ ] about them I miss
pretty much oh yes what yeah I mean it
makes it more relevant cuz you didn't
get a picture with him he's saying
that's all like they're using him to be
like I knew this guy like I met him yeah
so this what he said he was like that's
stupid yeah I don't think they're doing
especially Hugh Jackman like when you're
nobody and you have a random picture
what Stanley maybe I can see it that way
there's like oh I do have some relevance
with this guy but when you work on a
franchise like five movies straight and
someone that you've develop a
relationship with them yeah and you're
cherishing your relationship to with
that person well his particular point
here is that he says if Stan impacted
your life with his work then post his
work that touched you the most posting a
selfie makes his desk taking a picture
with him no he's just being a dumb [ __ ]
right now cuz my husband so we're not
fairs when someone becomes your personal
friend like if like let's say God forbid
David passes away right I'm not gonna
poke I'm not gonna post David's
look at this video he inspired me so
much like Kim jong-il oh I'm not gonna
post Kim Jong hello I'm a post me and
David's picture we were in Hawaii
chilling because became friends I think
the majority agree with you guys because
he did get a lot of [ __ ] stupid do
yours complain so much
someone is [ __ ] someone just passed why
the [ __ ] are you
the [ __ ] are you doing this like
honestly I feel like he made it about
himself yeah cuz it's like everyone
should be allowed to talk about it
however they want to yeah it regardless
if it's genuine or not right like that's
that's up to the universe to start that
[ __ ] out but it's like if you're gonna
more and then do it the way you want a
mourn or remember someone yeah shut up
to this guy I don't like him any I love
those people are adamant about their
opinions about what you should do this
is how you should express yourself it
was only one appropriate way to express
yourself and it's my way if your answer
is to post a selfie then I think we need
a cultural revamp a cultural leave
actual my opinion is so wonderful that
everyone should follow we need a
cultural revamp like one here's my
opinion [ __ ] that turtleneck of yours
that [ __ ] is yeah that [ __ ] was ugly it
looks like a [ __ ] roll of toilet
paper on your neck bro take that [ __ ]
off how about that yeah it looks like
your dick I mean my looks like my dick
and your head is popping out of it oh
how pretentious you gotta be to wake up
and be like I'm walking the red carpet
today margaret's get my turtleneck
[Laughter]
Stanley probably not that's what I'm
saying jealous even in the Marvel
Universe at all
did he play any character well he did
say that he did work with him but uh
what go did not your fault though I
think that's was just better like out of
the millions of characters he could have
played he didn't get a single one I
think he didn't get a picture with
Stanley yeah that's what happened hands
up saying about Mark Ruffalo's picture
where he posted a photo let's go that's
what it should have been yeah yeah he
says like this makes me feel like Mark
Ruffalo's posed was genuine Oh where's
his post about Stan all he's doing is
brain negativity towards Stan anyways
like what the [ __ ] do you do a bro like
we're all supposed to be like it's kind
of like the thing with the California
fires we should be all community as a
community morning like this tragedy or
this thing that happened or this death
but instead there
like well let's vilify someone list
vilified Kim Kardashian let's vilify the
people that posted photos with him I'm
like I want this man hung by his
turtleneck how about that
[Music]